what were some of those challenges early
on on that leadership journey where
you're no longer just focused on your
own number your own performance your
then response to other people's
performance what were some of the early
challenges do you think um certainly i
think you know we talked about time that
you know the billing team leader is the
toughest position yeah and it's about
you have to learn to let go of certain
things both in terms of financially you
think well i can make money out of this
myself
but you're probably better off actually
enabling someone in your team to make
money off themselves as well um so that
that's that's a tough transition i think
it's difficult to stop i mean when i was
a leader at the beginning i was just
controlling you know i just said right
do it this way this is how you got to do
it yeah i wasn't really allowing anyone
any opportunity to innovate themselves
or flourish i just wanted some i was
very directive why was that because you
just knew what worked for you so you're
like i'd rather just just do what i've
done because
you think it's just an easier way to get
to success yeah and i think i didn't
know how to manage properly didn't have
a lead properly only my way worked so
that's that's what i'm going to roll out
of everyone and they're going to have to
do it that way and that's really common
but like so i guess someone that might
be listening to this right now that
might have that approach what would you
say to them to think about to get them
to think about
maybe yeah if it isn't just do this
because it worked for me
like what what would be the what would
the advice be for those that are going
through that transition that may have
might have that leadership mindset i
think now more than ever people don't
want that approach i think people will
respond certainly the younger
generations coming through respond less
to that people wouldn't want the ability
to innovate themselves and do things
their own way i think you need to create
the boundaries around what what
shouldn't shouldn't happen but i think
people need to be able to find their own
way
the recruitment mentors podcast is
proudly sponsored by vincerie and the
award-winning sauce breaker
[Music]